株式会社
代表取締役社長
です
皆さんは社長というものをご存知でしょう
か一般的に会社のトップと言いますか会社
をまとめる人を
社長というんですけれども会社に所属する
以上はやっぱり社員がいたりとか部下がい
たりでみんな何で会社に所属するか
もちろん会社とかその売り上げを出すため
でもありますが
給料もらうためだとも言いますね
頑張りに見合ってお金をもらう給料という
ものがあります学生の方で働いてる方い
ないかもしれませんがバイトとかしたらね
お金もらえるようになるんですよ皆さんは
このYouTuberはじめしゃちょー県
代表取締役会社の女性を出始めの
給料どれくらいだと思いますか多分1回も
言ったことないんですよなんかいつもこの
目指して大体これぐらいですとかそれなり
にもらってるんでしょうとかなんかこう
アバウトにごちゃごちゃしたんですけれど
も今日の企画は私
初めての1ヶ月の給料1日で使ってみた
[音楽]
いいです私
夏YouTube
頑張りました会社頑張りましたたまには
こういうねなんか1ヶ月の給料をまるまる
ボカンって使ってみたらどうなるかとか
はじめ社長は何を買うんだっていうのもう
ほんとちょっとプライベートぽくね本当は
自分の
欲しいものしたいことにお金を使ってみ
たいと思いますこれ必然的に何が起きるか
というと超一日で僕
給料分全部使うので最終的に全部合計し
たら僕の給料がわかるという仕組みになっ
てますのでいろんなお店に行くと思います
が今日1日のはじめしゃちょー見て僕の
給料をぜひ感じてみてくださいでは早速
最初のお店行ってきます
では行こう
はいというわけでまずはこちらアルペン
東京さんスポーツ用品店に来ました結構
プライベートでもやってるのでバスケ
グッズ全然今ないから服とかバスケだけに
も限らず何かこうスポーツ用品最近買い
たいなと思ったのでここでまず買っていき
たいと思いますじゃあバツバツに使って
いきましょうはいでは早速見ていき
ましょううわすげー俺めっちゃ久々に
スポーツショップ来たんだけど東静岡駅に
したバスケできる公園で来たじゃん
ちょっとマイバスケットボール欲しいなっ
て気持ちはあります正直これとかめっちゃ
かっこよくね色おしゃれ白赤だないや
分かりやすいように青とかにしようこれに
しますもし買いますもう確定
[音楽]
えバスケットを広くないあそこだけと思っ
てたらもうこの黒はほぼバスケらしいです
じゃあボールとかも俺なんか安易に選んだ
けど黒とかのがかっこいい気がしてきたな
これで75ですか
[音楽]
あと何買う
服ですか
服も欲しいねバスケット系のウェアも
欲しいし広いからもっとちゃんと見たい
気持ちはあります
めっちゃ発音ありましたこれ
多分日本代表だね日本の欲しいよね
上はどうしよう
派手なの行くかじゃあもうこれ行っていい
買います
淡い色のやつがちょっと好きだったりする
ので
これも行きますねこれとか派手すぎる
夏っぽい俺っぽいかな
やっぱコートで目立ってなんぼだから
じゃあこれはセットアップで行くわこれで
買います
やばいなんか全部痒く見えてきたどう
しようだいぶねお買い物モード入ってき
ました自分がお金使えるんだっていうそう
いう感覚が入ってきてます
でイケてる160のLってどう
ちょいパツン
ちょい
XLあるわじゃあこれも買いますやっぱ
白枠がかっこいいよなじゃあこの赤も
ジャスティスでいいですかもう
寒くなるから長袖とかもひょっとしたら
買っといた方がいいのかもしれないね結構
爆買いしてるけど大丈夫かな
バッシュケース欲しいんだったこれ場所
ケースですね
かっこいい買います入れようと中用で2つ
買いますねやばいマジで
過ぎてる
黒1個しかないけどちょっとヘッドバンド
も買いますさあバッシュ買いましょうか
このシリーズ好きなんですよこの店
スライムカラーとかでいいよねこれの28
ってあります
これ大事ですよ
在庫切れ
[音楽]
新しいカラーではありますかこれ買います
白い場所履くイメージないめっちゃある
足元白い方が軽く見えるっていう
持論がありまして黒ってさそのきゅって
しまって見えるけどなんか重く見える
イメージがあるから俺はバスケは足元白が
結構好きですね
こちらもこちらもあるかもしれない
あーなるほどなるほど
[音楽]
両方お願いします俺マジで破産しに行っ
てるでもそういう企画ですもんね
迷ったら2つ買えばいいんですもんね
こんなことしたことないよ俺
リュックも買おうかな俺これやばいぞ
ボールとシューズと上や収納できるよ
そんなことがあっていいのだろうかバスケ
行く時さリュックなかったんだよね荷物
入れるの来たねこれ全部入るでしょ絶対
これ
買いすぎてる他にもいろんな店舗行く予定
なのでちょっとここで買い切らないように
気をつけたいですねここがやばいでしょ
バッシュ1個でいいのよただ室内用と外用
かなと思ってるので
かっこいいこのホワイトスライムスカイ
レッドグリーンとスカイレットグリーンと
こっちのこのピンクのポイントが入ってる
白いやつ結構
満足いく量を変えてる気がしますじゃあ
これでお会計行ってきたいと思いますお
会計中なんですけど俺さ
値段水買ってることに気づいたのよ
ちらっとさ上の値段見たら結構高かったん
ですけど何円ぐらいなんだろう金額
[音楽]
失礼します
なるほどねじゃあ買ってきます
[音楽]
買いましたはいやばい
結構買いましたねでもなんか今まで買い
たかったバスケ用品
欲を全て発散できた気がします
すごい量だよちょっと金額見ていき
ましょうか
レシートというわけで1店舗目スポーツ用
品店でのはじめしゃちょーの爆買い金額
[音楽]
14万7719円14万円
約15万ですねやばいよ
15万結構
盛大に行きましたねちょっとこんなに行く
と思ってなかった10万以内に抑えれるか
なと思ったらちゃんとしっかりこれで行っ
てしまいました
[音楽]
まだ行けますまだ大丈夫です次の店舗いき
ましょう
はいというわけで次は家電量販店野島さん
に来ました家電でございますよはい電化製
品もほんと何でも売ってるからちょっと
特に欲しいものないんですけれども4
kのお家の4階が今結構僕のお家みたいに
趣味かみたいになってるのでそこで何か
必要なものとかあったら買いたいなと思っ
てます早速見ていきましょう
失礼します
これ90万とかするんだってあーなるほど
ね行っちゃうのもまた一つの手かもしれ
ないね
やめておきます
[音楽]
ノジマの店員さん流してくれたこれ俺の
動画流れてるんだけどあーでもこういう
なんか安いのもあるね
10万切ってるぐらい
なるほどねーテレビがでもうちあるよね
一応大きいのありますテレビは多分大丈夫
だと思いますあーやばい楽しみ
楽しい楽しい
ぞ音楽は
大丈夫です他の見に行こう他の
あーなるほど空気清浄機の類ですね
ちょっとこれからどんどん寒い季節になっ
てくると思うので秋とか冬とか絶対乾燥
するんで加湿器とかちょっと欲しいかも
しれないな
[音楽]
オレンジでもなんかあったよね空気清浄機
どれくらい使ってるんですか
[音楽]
使ってるとこ見たことない
空気清浄機置いてあった気がするんだよね
だとしたら加湿器かななんかめっちゃ良さ
そうじゃないかっこいいですね形も
シンプルでちょっと候補結構ありた気がし
ます
うわーすごい
めちゃくちゃいろんなのがあるあーこう
いうねお掃除ロボットとかね結構
良さそうな気もするなぁちょっとあり結構
候補です正直ね絶対俺やんないじゃん絶対
やんないんだったらロボットにやらせて
おいた方がいいのかなと思う
[音楽]
やはりそのユーチューバーとしてはビデオ
カメラとかみたいですね
やっぱこれずっとあるんだこのカメラ
ずっと昔からあるんだけどやっぱ今も人気
なのかなずっとあるよねこれ見ますねこれ
持ってるから良い
なるほどねスマホのスタビライザーとか
あるこれであのブレなくなるのよこうやっ
てスマホ用の
ジンバルいいな
えやばい
これ持ってるやつだコンパクトでめっちゃ
使いやすいんですよこれは4台持ってます
カメラ類も足りてるないやさっきのあの
スマホ用のスタビライザーはちょっと魅力
を感じました
いやー俺持ってたんだけど無くしたんです
よねちょっと
欲しいなとは思うやっぱさ高いじゃん高い
のもあるからあんまり手軽に買います買い
ませんできないのでさっきみたいに
いいよね
[音楽]
欲しいけどこれも結構ねあるのよ俺結構
持ってるなやっぱ1回さその
YouTuberじゃない方の生活の部分
に当てましょうかフォーカスを
なにこれ美顔器かどうするけど3日で俺
なんかやらなくなりそうだよね
あーなるほどねコーヒーマッサージのやつ
とかどう気持ちいいやつですね買うわこれ
この頭皮マッサージのやつちょっといいな
これ触っていただきます4階の俺の部屋に
足りないもの電子レンジだ電子レンジない
わうち電子レンジないことに今気づいた
一番いいの買うか
これでかいなでかいからこれにしますでも
オーブン使うかって言われるとちょっと
わかんないんだよなだったら電子レンジ
だけでいいような気もするどうしよう
何もわからないこれだけやるとどれがいい
のかわからないです僕おすすめ聞きたい
ですか電子レンジだけが欲しいね料理し
なくてもさすがに使うのよすいません
電子レンジの買いたいんですけど
とりあえず
めっちゃいいやつはい
値段あんまり断らないなく
とかって使われるオーブンは使わないと
思います
[音楽]
オーブンレンジにちょっと見たいです
ねこれにしますはいこれ買いますはい
ありがとうございます俺実はね買い物の
判断めちゃくちゃ早いんだよ迷いなかった
です
もうちょっと見てもらおうか
電動歯ブラシねーなかなかさ買おうと思っ
て買わないじゃんそれこんなに出すんだ
34万ぐらいするけど結構せっかくだから
買おうかなこういう機会じゃないと買わ
ない気がするんだよなナンバーワンあり
ますよ
これ
じゃあこれだわよくわかんないけどこれ
買いますえでも4階にさあでっかい冷蔵庫
欲しくない一番欲しい
行くか俺的にはさあの空間に合うかどうか
かっこいいかどうかめっちゃ大事なんです
よね個人的にはこれがめっちゃかっこいい
なって思っちゃったただ反射するから動画
撮影してる時なんかカメラマンとか写っ
ちゃいけないものが映りそうな気がするの
であんまりこのミラー型良くない気もし
ますねこれもすごい反射する
[音楽]
待って冷蔵庫多くねどう思うこれこそ聞い
た方がいいんじゃないですか
冷蔵庫も欲しくなっちゃったんですけど
はいどれぐらいの大きさでご検討されて
いる冷蔵庫ってやっぱりこのなんか特徴
あったりするんですかそうですね結構
メーカーさんによって変わってきて
くるんですお部屋が三菱さんちょうど今
ご覧いただいてるものとかだとお部屋が
全部バラバラの設計になっているので中で
繋がってなくて匂いとか下に行かなかっ
たり
人気のあるメーカーさんでしたりとか冷凍
室と野菜の位置が変わってきたなるほど
なるほど
お部屋の場所とかも見た方がいいって感じ
ですね
いやー個人的に
これぐらいシンプルなの
いいなぁ
両方から開けれるのすごい便利なんだけど
匂いでかいなぁ買いますありがとうござい
ます
大丈夫かなこの選び方ででも匂いがない
扉どっちからでも開けられる大きさも
そんなでかすぎないというベストかなと
思いますね
鏡じゃないのをでかいいや間違いないと
思いますちょっとそろそろ値段が怖くなっ
てきましただいたい買うもの決まったので
ちょっと会計行ってきますこちらですね
まあまあこんな感じですよねたくさん買い
ましたしこちらでよろしくお願いします
[音楽]
買ってきました
もうちょっと買ったんですけども
商品が後日発送ということで今も近いれる
のはこの2点です電子レンジと歯ブラシ
ですね電動歯ブラシは今持ち帰れます
野島さんで買ったのが4品買いましたあの
ヘッドスパの電池バイヘッドスパのやつと
電動歯ブラシと電子レンジと冷蔵庫4つ
買いましたたくさん買うというより本当に
必要な家電を買わせていただきました気に
なる合計金額
27万710円
[音楽]
合計金額出してみましょうか
合計金額さっきのと合わせると
41万8429円です
この一瞬ね40万ぶっ飛びました
まだ行けます
40万ぐらいでこの社長のユーチューバー
の社長の給料なんて全然まだ行けますよ
だけど2店舗で40万超えてしまいました
がちょっとお腹空きましたねお昼なのでお
昼ご飯もちょっと
盛大に食べに行こうかないきましょう
[音楽]
はいというわけでお昼ご飯なんですけども
お昼ご飯も
給料バッチリ使っていくために高級
焼肉店に来ました行きましょう
[音楽]
見てこのドア
がもう重いのよ
失礼します
冷ましまーすはいこちら
銀座の焼肉屋さん入草木さんに来ました
ここ初めて来たんですけどもちょっと
美味しいということでここで今日は
スーパーランチ食べたいと思いますいき
ましょうエレガントに個室で失礼します
かっこいい
失礼します
ここでじゃあお昼ご飯食べようかな
[音楽]
じゃあメニュー表黒ちょっと値段見てみて
いいどれくらいなんだろうっていうに銀座
よザ銀の
焼肉屋さんなんて
なるほどですね俺やっぱ価値観バグっ
ちゃってるのかなさっきなんか40万とか
使っちゃってるからなんか全然いけるわ
みたいな感じになっちゃってますじゃあ
早速頼みましょうか
[音楽]
よろしくお願いします
この店で一番高いお肉をいただいても
よろしいでしょうか当店の高いお店と
シャトーブリアンでございますけど
シャトーブリアかしこまりましたね
とりあえずそちらを一ついただけるとはい
勝ちましたよろしくお願いします
やばい値段水頼んじゃったやっぱ一番と
いえばシャトーブリアンなんだね
高いビーチしかないそうだねせっかく今
一緒に来てるから2人で食べるかいいん
ですかはい後輩におごるのも込みで社長の
給料だと思ってるのでたくさんですね
[音楽]
はいありがとうございます
いやそういうことよね誰かと食べる焼き肉
の方が美味しいからとりあえずシャトーブ
には食べてこの店の最高を知ってそこから
ちょっとご飯とかね色んなもの食べていき
たいと思います
ありがとうございます
すげーすごいの来たよ
輝いておりますねこのお肉はこれですね先
に次のメニューも頼んじゃっていいです
けどはいじゃあコーラ2つと和牛
サーロインのすき焼きあと特選カルビも一
つあと
美味しそうですね
盛り合わせを一つください白米を2つ
とりあえずこれぐらいではいはいよろしく
お願いしますお願いしますじゃあ早速焼い
ていいですかお願いします行きますお願い
します
エレガントな音がするね待って焼けるの
めっちゃ早いんだけど
これでそろそろ良さそうです
いただきます
いい感じなのでいただきます
こういうのですもうガッツリ行ったほうが
いいと思うんだよね行くねもう行くねお
願いします
[音楽]
ちょっと待ってこれやばい
柔らかすぎる
余裕で紙切れたんだけどなんかあのハサミ
準備していただいてるんですけども全然
いらんもう
[音楽]
声をちょっと待って本当にうまいぞこれ
もう1枚食べたいな次のさぁ
渡すから食べていいいただきます
いやこれやばいわなんか高いお肉って
脂身が強いみたいなイメージありますけど
全然そんなことないです重くないですね
結構すっと食べられるこれちょっと手に
味わってほしいなてちょっと食べない
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
美味しいです
あと4個ですかけど
油っぽくはないという
一口パクリ
[音楽]
なんかうざいな
頼みすぎました
これなんかやばいよ頼んでる気がするん
ですけど多分美味しいのでさらっと
食べれる気がしております
かね
[音楽]
軽くね
火を通してこれをこうやって
卵にぶっこみます
[音楽]
とこうやってこれをいっぱい靴に運びます
失礼します
[音楽]
マジでうまい
ちょっとお腹あれ
びっくりしたびっくりした
ややいっぱいあのねシャトーブリアンが
思ってに満腹感がやっぱすごくて子供には
多分ついて俺だったら無理でしょちょっと
あのマネージャーさんとかも今日来てるの
でみんなで食べたいと思いますそれを計算
して
頼みましたパーティー
皆さんの営業だけ食べてください
[音楽]
はいというわけで頼みすぎて一人で食べれ
なかったので注意とスタッフの皆さんで
全部食べ終わることができました
[音楽]
もうかったけどめっちゃ美味しかったです
最初初手で
3個その時点で2万近く行ってるんで
お会計まじでどうなってるんだろう
ちゃんとね社長の
給料なんか食べ方はできたかなと思います
ありがとうございますお願いしますお願い
します
[音楽]
はいありがとうございますはいありがとう
ございますはいえー金額の方お昼ご飯
焼肉
8万2643円
8万いきました
8万2643円今のところ合計が
今どこうわぁやばい50万超えた今の
ところ合計が
50万1072円使っております
拍手なのかわからんけどまだ大丈夫です僕
のはじめ社長の給料ですからこんな50万
程度で止まるような給料じゃありません次
行きましょう
はいお昼ご飯食べ終わりました社長です
一旦ちょっと休憩で東京の渦に戻ってき
ましたちょっとねお店じゃなくてメルカリ
でも欲しいものがあるのでメルカリで
ちょっとこの休憩時間に買っていきたいと
思いますなかなかねメルカリだとお店とか
で売ってない手に入らないようなものも
あるんですよ皆さん何だと思いますかそう
ヘラクレス用品ヘラクレス用品なんですよ
ヘラクレス専用のものとかってなかなか
見つからなくて本当にいい物ってね手に
入らなかったりいっぱいに売られてなくて
個人で作ったりしてるものもあるのでもう
そういうのがメルカリだと結構あったり
するので今回こういう機会なのでそれも
買っちゃいたいと思いますまず欲しいの
こちらです人工蛹室何ヘラクレスセット何
これって思うじゃんこれ
めっちゃ大事なんですよこれどういう商品
かというとヘラクレスの
洋室
鼻毛になった時のお部屋を作るアイテム
ですこんなのね俺お店で見たことないのよ
もう書いてある通りですね人口蛹室10秒
で作れヘラクレスオオカブトなどを飼育
するならかっこいいヘラクレスオオカブト
を成虫がないと思います一般のケースで
飼育していると大型のカブトムシはどうし
ても狭くて
蛹になる時にケースの端にぶつかりつのが
曲がるなんてこともそうなのよ
ヘラクレスオオカブトでかいから
蛹になる場所とか角度によってはなんか角
が
ケースの中に容器にぶつかっちゃって
曲がっちゃうこともあるんで人工蛹室人間
がヘラクレスのために蛹用のお部屋を準備
するっていうのが結構主流なんですよそれ
を作れるというアイテムがメルカリに売っ
てましたこれ
8925円これ買わせていただきますこれ
はね多分お店に行って探すとかよりかは
こういうメルカリで買った方が絶対早いと
思いますでは早速購入していこうと思うん
ですけれども皆様僕も今日お会計で何回か
使ってますこちらのメルカードご存知
でしょうかこのミルカードクレジット
カードなんですけれども見てナンバーレス
ナンバー書いてないんですよ
めっちゃスタイリッシュじゃない
クレジットカードってさ基本的にあの何桁
から数字書いてあるんですけどメルカート
何も書いてありません
めっちゃスタイリッシュでこのメルカード
を使ってメルカリで買い物するとなんか
すごいお得らしいので今回やめるカードを
使ってお買い物していきたいと思います
どんどん買っていきましょう次はこちら
飼育ケースヘラクレスの
飼育ケースのクリアボトル36個
めっちゃ多いめっちゃ多いけど今の幼虫の
数だったらこれぐらい欲しいんですよ
ねフィルター付き保湿小林いやもうまさに
これが欲しかったというサイズのそして
飼育管理Love付き買いますちょっと
この飼育ケースは是非ともお得に買いたい
と思います8600円買わせていただき
36個だとちょっと俺多分もうちょっと
腰痛増えると思うので不安なのでさらに
18個追加しますこれもお得だよ同じやつ
ですね
午前300円買いますやっぱりその
昆虫ショップとかに売ってるマットって
結構同じやつばっかりだったりするんで
こういう特殊なヘラクレスのマットをメル
カリ売ってたんで買ってみたいなと思い
ましたこれ買わせていただきます
7400円です
ポチあーやっぱ売れてるななんか
ヘラクレスの標本とかもかっけえなと思っ
たんですけども売れてる結構やっぱみんな
かっこいいから好きなんだなフィギュアと
かでいいかななんかかっこいいフィギュア
とか買っちゃおう
あんまり見ないからヘラクレスの雰囲気だ
とか
でかくね
ゲーセンの商品なのいいですねちょっと
この
巨大ヘラクレス買わせていただきます
購入これめっちゃいいなぁな大型餌代足場
材セット
ヘラクレスオオクワガタ用なんかその
ヘラクレスに餌あげる時ヘラクレス角大き
すぎてなんか食べるのすごい難しそうなん
ですよゼリーでこの大きめのなんかゼリー
置く用の餌皿はすごいいいですねこんなの
もなかなか売ってないよショップでもう
ちょっと普通の木とかしか売ってないので
これちょっと変わっていただきますはいと
いうわけでメルカリでですねヘラクレス
グッズ大量に買いましたもうねやっぱお店
とかで買えないものだったらこういうね
メルカリとかで調べて買うのがね結構
早かったりするのでおすすめですこれは
いい買い物したなと思いますメルカリでの
購入金額
[音楽]
35205円
結構安くぎゅっと収まったのではない
でしょうかすごい良かったよ
育成用のボトルとか50個以上買ったから
かなりでっかい買い物したと思いますはい
まだまだありますこんな程度じゃ私の
給料が減りませんよちょっと休憩してから
次の店行きたいと思います
[音楽]
どうも階段から見てわかると思うんです
けどもまたすごいところに来ました最後は
こちら
高級家具屋に来ましたこれだねお店の名前
こちらです
[音楽]
マスターボール
銀座にある高級家具屋さんに来ております
もうねやっぱり何だろう動画抜けてお金
バット使ったらやっぱり家具とか揃えて
動画映えもそうですし生活に
彩りというかおしゃれなカフェに囲まれて
生活するのかっこいいなって思って家具屋
に来ました家具ってね
おしゃれだったりいい袖使ってる家具も
本当にびっくりするぐらい高くてさすがに
これはね俺の給料にとどめさすんじゃない
かっていう気がしております早速見ていき
ましょう失礼します
[音楽]
これ見て
いやすごいよ
めっちゃおしゃれですよ
いやおっさん見てこの金の
ポテトチップ
スかっこいいなやっぱ金のこういう影って
めっちゃ俺好きなのよねかっこよくない
イメージある本当に金のイメージあるとか
なんかこういうね高いところから吊るす
こういう照明とか4kのうちの4階にさ
あれわかるなんかテスラポットみたいな
感じの机あそこの上とかにこれ吊るして
やったらめっちゃおしゃれだなって思うん
だけどちょっと店員さんに聞いてみたいと
思いますこれは買えますか
[音楽]
なるほどなるほど
かっこいいめっちゃいいですねこれ中川
さんも調節できるやつですよねショート
カットで合わせて
いただける
すごいおしゃれだなと思ってちょっと
候補ですけども結構値段がね来たかったよ
ねこれは何ですか
おしゃれネタとか思いついたらすぐ
かけれるみたいなおしゃれだなぁ
でも値段見ちゃったけどこれもなかなか
やりますよ4回に何いるかだよねそうです
ね一通りも必要なもの今日家電も行ったし
揃ったからこっからは本当にいかに
オシャレに振り切れるかと思うのよ
あと僕の給料とかもそうなんですみんな
わかんないもんね俺がどんぐらい残ってる
か俺だけ知ってるのよねあとどれぐらいお
金が使えるかがちょっとそこの計算
すり合わせしながら買っていきたいです
こういうのとか買ったらめっちゃ可愛く
ないなんか南国味があってすごい好きだな
Lサイズ
めっちゃかっこいいやばい欲しいの結構俺
格式なんですよねどうしてオーバーし
ちゃったら
企画破綻かな
給料ないってことだもんねこれもですか
これはもうそれぞれやっぱ大きさによって
値段が変わってくるんですか
はい
ほうほうほうほう
なるほどなるほどいやこれかわいいね
[音楽]
迷う
迷うぞソファとかどんぐらいなんだろう
この照明さぁあそこつくと思う
あったっけそもそも上にあの吊るせるやつ
あったっけなちょっと自分の家の構造を
理解してないんだよねちょっと写真見返し
てみるわ家のなんか写真たくさん撮っとけ
ばよかったな
めっちゃかっこよくねこれ置いてあったら
でもおしゃれですね
その上まで取らんか普通どっちだ行けない
のか行くしかないか買ってから考えるか
いや決めましたこの
細いペンみたいなのとてもおしゃれで
編集机の上とかにちょっと置いときたいな
と思いました買いますこれ買わせて
ください
なんかこういうの1個あるだけの変わり
そうだよねソファーは最近買った椅子も
高いのが実は置いてるんです今俺に必要な
のは照明そして間接照明お部屋を彩る
醤油アイテムが欲しい
[音楽]
買いますこれ買いますまだ行けるのかいつ
も見ていいですか
失礼いたしますこれもあれじゃないこれ
とこめっちゃいいね
すいませんこれも買えますか
なかなか見ないよねこんなの
キッチンで少し
納期にお時間いただくかも人気なんですか
人気なんだ
えーでもちょっとぶっ飛びたいよね
買いますこれ買いますなんか普通の壁が
コンクリートで結構黒いのがいっぱいいる
んでこれはその立てかけるやつですよね黒
映えそうだよねうち
これとこれ買います2つお願いします
選んでいただいてた海外の照明が取り寄せ
になるので
約半年ぐらいお時間いただく可能性があり
ます
半年かでもそれだけ人気ってことですよね
ちなみにさっき見たあの天井から
ぶら下げるやつとあの照明は
してる可能性が高いのでお
届けが可能ですあちらのスタンドはもしか
したら半年の可能性もあります
正直僕はこれが一番響いてますねやっぱ
なかなか家にさこういうアーチの照明と
あるものじゃないから
めちゃくちゃオシャレなんだよなぁこれ見
てすごい重い
[音楽]
これいいねいや
半年かかってでも僕はいいと思ってます
お姉さんこれ買います
こういうフックでかけれますあーなるほど
なるほどじゃあこれレベルかけといて
もらっていいコンクリートじゃない壁の
部分も多分あると思うのでちょっと工夫し
て
飾ってみたいと思います白いよね結構壁
白いので黒すごい映えそうなのでそちらも
ぜひ買わせてくださいお会計よろしくお
願いします
[音楽]
はい
買ってきました
[音楽]
何も持ってないです家具買ったんですけど
もでかすぎてお家に届けてもらうので今は
特に何も持ってませんがこちらの高級家具
屋さんで買わせていただいた金額
[音楽]
46万2000円
ちょっと少なくないですか
20万円超えの家具4つぐらい入れません
でしたよ入れたっけあれえ入れてましたよ
ね
実はここで終了です
買えませんでした俺の給料でもういろいろ
欲しいのたくさんあったんですけども
ちょっと引かせていただいて何個かに絞っ
て買わせていただきました黒いあの壁に
貼れるやつ2枚とこういう照明めっちゃ
かっこよかったやつそれしか僕の給料では
買えませんでしたはいというわけでお
買い物終了
[音楽]
家帰ります
はいというわけで
商品たくさん届きました
お店で買ったものとかもあるんですけれど
もメルカリで買ったものとか届きました
ただねやっぱりその家電冷蔵庫とかこう
いうアーチ型の照明とかまだ届いてないの
で全部ではないんですけれども結構届き
ましたというわけでバスケ用品とかはね
もう買いながら見せたからある程度分かる
と思うんですけどバッシュケースバッシュ
2速バスケットの上はたくさんボール
バスケ用のリュックとかも買いましたで
家電が電動歯ブラシ
電子レンジでメルカリに届いたものこれで
蛹の部屋を作りますこれがヘラクレスの土
ですねマット届きました
ではこんなにお店でも買えないよこれは
メルカリで正解ですわ大きくなった後の
容器買ってなかったのでこれでヘラクレス
の腰痛が大きくなっても育てられますで
容器がもう1セットありますいいねいい量
だこれだけあれば560匹のヘラクレスの
幼虫はお世話できると思いますそしてこれ
が
カマキリとヘラクレスのフィギュアですね
でかすぎだろこういうのラボとかに
ヘラクレスラボで飾っておきたいなと思っ
たので買いましたはいというわけでこんな
感じではじめしゃちょー1日で
社長の給料全て使ってみました
どうでしょうなんとなくの金額見えました
でしょうか行ったお店としては今回
スポーツ用品店電気屋さん高級焼肉店メル
カリでちょっと買い物そして高級家具屋
さんで買わせていただきましたが最終的な
合計金額がですね本舗初公開私はじめしゃ
ちょーの
給料となっておりますこれね
どう思われるか心配だなあの間違いなくね
そのあのその
稼いでいるのあんまり言いたくないけど
稼いではいるんですけども
稼いだお金全部使うわけがないとそして
そんなことしてるとなんか価値観が狂っ
ちゃっておかしくなっちゃうということで
僕の給料こんな感じだっていうので発表さ
せていただきます今回私が1日で使わせて
いただきました
給料
[音楽]
99万8277円です
100万円です
年間1000万ぐらい実は僕ねあの個人的
に使わせていただいておりますどう思い
ましたもっと使ってると思いました
いやいやそんなお前はお金使ってんの
かって思いましたまあ人によって思うこと
はそれぞれでしょうただわかんないけど
なんか服とか買ったり後輩とかにも奢っ
たりしてなんやかんやねあの100万円
結構1ヶ月でぴったりと使うようにして
ますまあそれとは別にあの貯金とかはする
んですけどね給料として使えるお金
100万円ですけどもそれ以外にちゃんと
のあの
貯金みたいなのはちゃんとしてるとね
あのー
将来安心今回をたくさんお買い物して結構
使いましたこちらのカードメルカードなん
ですけれどもこちらのメルカードスマホで
すぐ作ってすぐ使えるみたいでなんか
めっちゃ話題になってるみたいですそして
即時生産を使えば限度額を気にせず使える
のも便利しかも10月2日までに入会する
と最大11,000円分1万1000円分
の得点がもらえるらしいのでちょっとぜひ
作ってみてください
めっちゃお得ですスマホですぐ作れますね
皆さん是非メルカードを作ってみて
ください
キャンペーンの詳細情報は動画の概要欄に
ありますのでぜひチェックしてみて
ください
めっちゃお得ですよあとかっこよくない
やっぱナンバーレスってちょっと
未来感じちゃうよねというわけであの僕
たまにね高いものとか身につけてると思う
んですけれども
給料決まってるんですよ給料の100万
オーバーしてるやつとか買ってたら
貯金崩してこいつ買ったんだなと思って
あの見てください以上はじめしゃちょーの
給料大公開でしたじゃあな
[音楽]